δεν θυμάμε ακριβοστό χρόνο πραγματικάανδοθυμαμε πολύ αρχικά και πολύ ετά δηλαδή ότα λέω μετά πριν
ίκοσυ χλόγια το μόνο πολιτικό ας πούμε ένδημαπου δεκτικά ήτα να είμαι στην πρώτι σκυόδι
κυβέρνηση του κυριου κληρίδη ως υπουργός βιομηχανίας μετά μου ζηητήθηκε αν μπορούσαλάγου μέρος πιο ενεργά
αλλά εν τοδεκτικά δε νομίζω ότι έχω ούτε την κλίση ούτε τα φόντα για να
είμαι πολιτικός χρειάζουνται άλλα πράγματα κάθει δουλειά χρειάζεται διαφοριτικά τα λέντα θεωρείτα την μπορεί να
αναπτεχθεί από μη περισσότερο η κυπριάκη φαρμακόδιομηχανία αφού κάστοτε κυβερνήσεις εδώσααν κίνητρα στηριξη σε ότι
αφοράτην ανάπτυξη αυτό ακριβή κίνητρα ι ανάπτυξη δεν έχουν δοθεί στη φαρμακοβιβοιχανία εγώ βλέπω ότη
φαρμακομε μηχανία μάλλον να σας πω κάτι άλλο ο κύριοςμε τσοτάκη στην ελαδα όπου ι
φαρμακοβιομηχανία ήταν ο πισθο δρομική θαλια για πάραπολλά χρόνια έχει στη ρίξει άμεσα και έμεσα
τη φαρμακοιομχανία ι αυτό το λόγο ι μερικές ελληνικές φαρμακοηαίς έχουν επενδήσει τεράστια ποσα έχουν
κατολθώσει να κάνουν μεγάλες εξαγωγιές στην αρχή ολι έλνες έβλεπαν τη δεταιρεία μουως ξεγώ μοναδιοική
στις εξαγωγίές την άπο ανατολί στην